yandy diaz will be in the leadoff spot
against the left-hander and the first
pitch of this game swung on and there's
a base head up the middle into center
field but jose martinez three career
advance against leblanc
ball right side going to go through
hooked up by santander and right field
the reigns have two men on the block may
take a chance right to the inside corner
with his best fastball but he knows
ahead in the county's either going to be
on the block or it's going to be inside
here it is
picked right to the inside part good
call coach the tampa bay rays are going
to turn to tyler glass now to try to
turn around this three-game losing
streak
there's a strike on the outside corner
97 out there one out base is empty
cut the miss got him on the fastball
down the 2-2 pitch breaking ball strike
three call that's uh mike cenino i think
thought that that was going to be ball
three
was getting ready to throw it back to
tyler glass now so with two outs
there's a four pitch walk and the bases
are loaded
and 95 is skied toward right center
argo still gone but he's there and makes
the catch top of the order for baltimore
now here's a bunt
halfway to the mound glasgow's throw is
gonna be in time
to get hayes
it was after the first pitch skies at
the center and this is exactly what
class now needed four pitches to
dispatch of the orioles
the long stuff that he's using tonight a
little bit different than what we saw at
fenway the other day 2-2 when he gets
adamus pulls the string at 80 miles an
hour two down
cut fastball this time
and the razor going in order and leblanc
is frustrating the radius hitters one
ball one strike to the cleanup hitter
nunez
oh there it goes i was just going to say
doesn't have a long ball this year he
does now
diaz
jumps on that ball and the orioles on
top as he hits his first home of the
season
well ahead of the count two and one real
looking for a pitch in the location here
and get the fastball and laces it in the
center field for an ib rbi base hit so
rio riese puts the orioles up two
nothing
rosso will lead off the sixth against
the left-hander wade leblanc and the
first pitch brasso sends a fly ball deep
to left all the way to the wall and that
baby's gone
home run for brasso on the first pitch
here in the six
and the raids are on the board
[Applause]
loves
to hit
at oriole park nobody down runners on
the corners pedro severino maybe he can
do what he did last night yeah
pace hit into right field
nice piece of hitting by pedro savarino
smith hustles the third not even a
seeing eye single it's an open space
single for pedro severino and it's three
to one baltimore here's ruiz walked in
the second inning
louise hit well the center field they
should get the run in
the tag and dwight smith will score
easily
martinez will be the hitter with him
loaded
and the pitch is
lifted into short center coming straight
in that's going to fall in front of
hayes a run will score a play of second
and i think he beat the throw there
so the rays get a run
round ball right side picked up by
alberto
safe at first
the rays will get a run
it's a one run game now four to three
diaz crossed the plate and lau reaches
on a fielder's choice and here's kevin
kiermeier to hit for renfro the
left-handed bat against castro
and the ground ball base heading to
right
crossing the plate
to tie this game
it's a 4-4 ball game keermeyer comes
through with a single into right we're
gonna go to extras here in baltimore
g-man choi will be the runner at second
base
left field
mullins fading back ball carrying he's
got it on the track and here comes joy
trying to tag they gotta play he's out
at third so a double play
mullins gets it into rio ruiz
and that runner on second is wiped out
two down and nobody on
with pat valencia with a chance to be a
hero holiday at third base that's the
game ending run
there's a looper into right field
orioles win it pat valencia with the
walk-off base hit and the orioles win it
in 11. that's good for that kid
the lake a utility player